devrait le vrai truc horrible c'est
qu'il a regardé Thierry sur cette
je suis le souffre-douleur de mon stage
et maintenant voici mon stagiaire Tom
villa
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est difficile de faire mieux tu
es d'accord très beau plateau ce soir
tiens
Kev Adams c'est chiant parce que moi je
suis censé faire des vannes aux invités
keV il remplit des élites au cinéma un
bide pour lui c'est un million d'entrée
franchement il y a que capillairement
parlant où là c'est il est prenable mais
c'est vrai il a fait son Vivement
Dimanche c'est plus jeune à voir eu son
émission c'est vrai en même temps
c'était pas compliqué le plus jeune
avant keV c'était Gérard Lenorman mais
enfin quand même
alors tiens votre votre nouveau film
s'appelle ami public voilà c'est
l'histoire d'un garçon qui organise un
faux braquage avec ses potes pour
réaliser le rêve de son frère malade
voilà en gros c'est un peu un mélange de
d'oce eleven's et du Téléthon mais sans
Georges Clooney et sans Sophie Davant
en tout cas très malin le dernier film
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a des
mauvaises critiques des gens un peu
malveillants on peut dire [ __ ] vous
êtes pas sympa les gars ça parle du
cancer quand même comme ça tout le monde
culpabilise mais ça marche très bien non
mais c'est vrai d'ailleurs ils auraient
pu le faire pour les Bronzés 3 ils
auraient pu le faire sur l'euthanasie
comme ça ça va éviter qu'il se fasse
défoncer c'est quand même ballon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça attaque vénère vénère
[Rires]
Franck le même début de carrière que
Michel Bernier il a commencé dans un
trio il y avait un nain et
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous venez pour votre deuxième
film voilà Pattaya qui est la vraie
fausse 8 des kaïra en Thaïlande la
Thaïlande Thierry vous connaissez ces
paysages ces îles sa gastronomie c'est
massage avec ou sans finition et alors
dans le film Pattaya vous jouez de votre
semblant c'est que Vin Diesel c'est la
vigne diesel c'est votre sosie américain
c'est la classe bon en France c'est
Philippe Etchebest c'est un peu plus
pourri
[Applaudissements]
Lambert Wilson alors là attention grand
monsieur c'est la classe la tournée avec
les plus grands réalisateurs et aussi
avec Fabien antoniane t
dans un petit peu la boule à facette un
coup comédien un coup chanteur là il
revient avec un album de reprise de Yves
Montant très très bon choix voilà c'est
vrai que les jeunes connaissent pas
forcément mais en même temps dans les
albums hommage il restait plus grand
monde tu vois entre Goldman Balavoine
Bashung Barbara Ferré bon là il restait
Yves Montand et Annie Cordy donc
forcément c'est le prochain
alors Thérèse vous êtes belle blonde et
vous parlez de sexe voilà comme Clara
Morgane bon sauf que vous c'est le
cerveau qui est bien rempli mais
vous êtes sexologue et vous passez dans
tous les collèges et les lycées de
France c'est sûr que les questions elles
ont dû évoluer tu vois aujourd'hui elle
est à l'époque on se demandait comment
on faisait les bébés bon aujourd'hui
c'est pour ou contre la bifle donc c'est
sûr que ça doit être un petit peu non
vous le dites voilà les ados ont
l'angoisse de la performance sexuelle
voilà et c'est vrai que qui a 20 ans on
se demande combien de temps on va tenir
alors qu'à à 60 on se demande combien de
temps on va attendre avant que ça vienne
[Applaudissements]
le vrai le vrai truc horrible c'est
qu'il a regardé Thierry sur cette
douleur de moustache
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu
Kev Adams que vous avez passé le casting
à l'époque du film LOL voilà mais la
directrice de casting vous avez recalé
parce qu'il y a pensé que vous feriez
Paris les jeunes vous avez des nouvelles
depuis qu'elle boss pour Plus Belle La
Vie maintenant
des bisous à toi
Lambert vous chantez Yves Montand
exactement comme dit ça c'est très
impressionnant c'est quoi l'intérêt
d'acheter votre album plutôt que celui
de mon temps à part non à part le fait
que vous pouvez faire des concerts et
des dédicaces
c'est ça
je suis présent Franck Gastambide Franck
sur le tournage de des Dalton à l'époque
vous occupiez du dressage de Rantanplan
je crois c'est ça qui s'occupait de
dresser Ramzy alors
et pour finir tes résergo vous êtes
sexologue dans une école catholique
privée d'ailleurs du coup c'est vous qui
gérez quand un enfant de cœur plaque un
prêtre
merci beaucoup
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu